Good afternoon,
everybody. Can you folks hear me on your headsets?
OK, good. Awesome.
Now, quick show of hands,
how many of you have experimented
with foundation models in the past 6 months?
OK, now keep your hands up
if you have actually gotten those experiments
into production.
There that gap
between what works in the demo and
what works in production,
that is what we're here to talk about
now teams everywhere are building
impressive prototypes, demos
with foundation models.
The demos look great.
stakeholders are excited.
Budgets are approved.
And then
production requirements show up.
Now production
doesn't care about your demos.
Production has two non-negotiable
demands. The first
is accuracy that you can defend.
Production means mistakes have
real consequences
compliance violations,
broken customer trust, and bad
business decisions.
The second non-negotiable requirement
is economics that works.
What works,
you know, in the demos and costs just dollars
can cost thousands of dollars in
production. And when those
inference costs hit your P&L,
Your CFO is going to ask you pointed
questions about ROI.
And so teams get stuck.
They try hitting accuracy targets
with larger and more expensive
foundation models.
Or they cut costs with
smaller models and the accuracy
drops below what the business can actually
accept. So teams
accept the false choice.
But this is not a law of physics.
It is a limitation of approach.
There is a way to deliver
both higher accuracy as
well as dramatically lower costs simultaneously,
and that is through model customization.
I am Summedhaswamy, and I lead
product management for developer
experiences in the SageMaker AI
organization. And today I'll discuss
how to customize and scale foundation
models using Sage Maker AI.
Following my talk,
my colleague Giuseppe, who's standing there,
will demonstrate these capabilities
live through product demos. You're actually
going to see advanced model customization
techniques in action,
so it's going to be an exciting
60 minutes.
So let's be clear, why customized
models?
Every business now has
access to the same foundation models
GPT,
Lama,
Queen. They're all available
through APIs.
Your competitors have
access to the same models.
They're solving the same problems
and they're targeting the same customers.
So where is your competitive advantage?
It is not in the models that you can
access, it is in what you can
actually teach them.
Now foundation models are
powerful generalists. They have a
broad knowledge
but no depth in your specific
domain. They don't know your
industry terminology,
your company's data,
your business rules,
or your brand voice.
So in production you're forced to
choose the largest and most expensive
models just to approach
acceptable accuracy.
And they still don't fully
understand your context.
And in addition to that, you're paying
premium inference costs to access those
largest and expensive foundation models.
Now when I tell you this, some of you may be thinking,
well, I can use prompt engineering.
I can use rag to add context
so that you can get higher accuracy,
and you're right,
for simple use cases that works
great. But at
production scale,
which has strict accuracy
as well as cost requirements,
those approaches, when they're used
alone, they hit a ceiling.
For example, take transaction
categorization where you are categorizing
millions of transactions daily
for reporting, for fraud detection.
You may think that getting a 92%
accuracy on those models sounds
great, but that also means
that for 8% of the cases
you're miscategorizing these
transactions,
that is compliance violations,
incorrect fraud flags,
and essentially you're losing your customers'
trust. That is
because your model is reasoning
like a generalist, not as
a specialist in your domain.
With model customization and fine
tuning,
this is fundamentally different.
What you're doing there is you're
encoding your business's domain
expertise
directly into the model's weights.
So the model learns to think like
experts in your domain.
So here is an
you know an example of
what changes when you customize a
model. You take a
smaller model,
let's say an 8 billion parameter
model rather than a 400 billion parameter
model,
and you can fine tune it on your proprietary
data,
data such as your transaction patterns,
customer interactions,
or your domain-specific rules.
That fine tuned small
model
outperforms larger models
on your specific task. Maybe not
on all general tasks, but on the
tasks that you care about, it can actually
outperform the larger models
because it has actually learned your domain
patterns.
And because it is smaller,
inference of those models is
actually going to cost you
one or two orders of magnitude,
that is 10x to 100x
cheaper
than doing inference with a larger model.
And most importantly, you're not trading
off performance for cost.
Customization delivers both.
In your organizations,
your proprietary data is
the one asset
that your competitors cannot replicate.
Model customization is how you
take that data
and turn that data into your competitive
advantage.
This all sounds great. So if customization
is so great it solves both these
problems, why isn't everyone doing
it already?
Because there was a tax.
Here is what customization actually
looks like.
Let's say you want to fine tune a model,
it sounds very straightforward,
but before you write even a single
line of code.
You're tweaking YAML configuration
files.
You're configuring your GPUs
for distributed training.
What instances should I use? How
many of them?
What is the fault tolerance strategy?
Then you're stitching together tools,
one tool for data preparation,
another tool for training,
a third tool for evaluations.
Nothing really talks to each other
and so you're writing glue code to tie
all of these tools together.
Finally, let's say you're running your experiment.
Let's say you're getting promising results,
but try to reproduce them.
Let's say you got 94% accuracy.
Which data set gave you that 94%
accuracy? What were the hyperparametters?
Without centralized tracking,
you're piecing together this information
through scattered notebooks, slack
messages.
So let's say you have battled through all of that
and then
your model is actually working and you
want to deploy that model.
Now that's a completely different set of
challenges.
You need to build infrastructure from scratch,
containerization,
versioning,
monitoring, rollback strategies.
And the audit trail.
Which data trained this model?
What is the lineage?
You're reconstructing all of this
information after the fact.
And so it's no surprise that teams
are spending like 80% of their time
on infrastructure and tooling and
only 20% of their time on the actual
AI problem that they want to solve.
So teams make the rational decision.
They stay with generic models
and they skip customization.
That's the customization tax.
But that friction,
it is solved.
So here is how we solve the customization
tax.
We rebuilt the entire customization
experience around 3 specific principles.
The first is serverless infrastructure.
With this, you don't configure clusters,
you don't plan capacity,
you don't select instances.
You simply submit a job
and we provision the resources,
we do the job of doing distributed
training, and we scale automatically.
You only pay for what you use,
not what you actually reserve like you
do with instances.
The second principle here is integrated
workflow.
One environment,
Sagemker Studio, takes you from
experiment to production.
We provide built-in data preparation
tooling.
We provide built-in evaluation
tooling. We provide built-in observability
tooling. You don't have to switch
tools.
You don't have to write glue code to connect
these tools.
You don't have to hunt through scattered notebooks
and Slack messages
to find what you did.
Everything is tracked,
versioned,
reproducible in one place.
And the 3rd principle here is production
ready techniques.
Supervised fine tuning,
direct preference optimization,
reinforcement learning,
these advanced model customization techniques,
they are available to you across a
broad set of models. Amazon
Nova models,
Lama,
Gwen, and many, many
more.
Both open weights as well as
proprietary models are available.
These are the same methods
that the top frontier labs
are using.
What we have done is we have packaged
these methods
for your production use cases
so that with a simple configuration
change you can make them work for
you rather than writing these
from scratch.
And you're going to see a demo of all of this very,
very soon. Focus
on your domain problem.
We handle infrastructure.
That is the fundamental shift.
The 80/20 split I spoke about
earlier,
we inverted it.
Now you can spend 80% of your time
on your AI problem and 20%
on the infrastructure and tooling.
Because that tax is
gone. So now
let me dive a little bit deeper into the customization
techniques that you can actually use.
If it moves forward. There you go.
Now, SageMaker gives you 3
production-ready techniques to choose from.
The first
is supervised fine tuning or
SFT. SFT
teaches your model domain knowledge.
You provide it with labeled examples, saying
that, for example,
here is the transaction,
here is the category, or
here is the customer question, here
is the answer.
The model learns through pattern
matching, you know, it absorbs your terminology,
your procedures,
your institutional knowledge.
This is how you move from a generic
AI
to AI that understands your
domain. The
model absorbs your patterns,
learns to recognize similar situations
when there is new data that is coming in.
But it only learns explicitly
what you teach it, right? It can't,
you know, start developing judgment
or reasoning beyond the data that you have
actually given it.
The second customization technique is
direct preference optimization.
DPO DPO teaches a
model judgment and style.
Now instead of labeled examples
like you saw with supervised fine tuning with
DPO you're showing the model
pairs of
responses,
things like, hey, this response
represents
our brand voice,
our risk tolerance. This response
does not. So you give it these kind of
response pairs and you're going to see an example in the demo.
The model
using those response pairs learns
your quality standards, your
decision making criteria,
and the subjective preferences that
define how your company operates.
This is particularly powerful
when the outcomes are hard to define
programmatically.
But once you
see the outputs, it's easy to recognize
which is a better response. This is when
you would use something like DPO,
for example,
asking a question such as, hey, does this
response sound professional?
Does it align with values?
DPO captures these nuanced
preferences that cannot easily
be reduced to simple rules.
This is how you move from AI
that knows your facts, which is what
you did with SFT,
to AI that actually sounds like you.
Now the 3rd technique
is reinforcement fine tuning.
This is to teach your model complex
reasoning. Reinforcement
fine tuning trains a model to
achieve outcomes that are very difficult to
define programmatically,
but
once you actually see the output, it
is easy for an AI to
evaluate
and give feedback,
AI or any other tool to be able
to evaluate and give feedback.
Now, for example,
uh, training a model to sound
helpful and empathetic,
this is a very interesting challenge. It's
very hard to capture this in code.
But you can't write explicit
code to define what is warmth
in speech, what is understanding in
speech, but you can give that
response to an AI model
and ask it feedback
on whether the response feels right.
So that's how reinforcement learning with
AI feedback works. The model generates
output. You take that output.
AI gives you feedback and a reward,
and then the model learns to actually optimize
for that reward.
That is RLAIF, reinforcement
learning with AI feedback.
This is great when
it's very difficult to say there's a clear right
and wrong answer, but it's somewhat nuanced.
But in some cases there's a very clear right
and wrong answer like coding or
math. And in these cases you
use something like reinforcement learning with
verifiable rewards wherein you
take a function that actually
verifies whether the output is correct or
not, gives that output
feedback to your model, and the model
will get the reward and try to optimize
for that reward.
So all of these techniques are
interesting in moving the complex reasoning
part of the model forward.
Now,
you can start simple and evolve as
needed based on your use case because
Sagemaker supports all these three.
So you can begin where it makes sense for your
use case
and scale up as your use case demands
more. So
where do you get started with building
with these techniques?
So what we realized was different
teams work differently.
So we built 3 experiences
for model customization.
The first is
In Sagemaker Studio UI
for visual workflows, you select
a model,
upload data,
configure training,
no code required. This is
perfect for rapid experimentation.
The second is AI agent guided
experience.
This one is in preview as of
today. And here
you describe your goal. You tell the
agent something like, Hey, I need to
fine tune a model for contract analysis.
The agent then asks you a bunch of
questions to learn more about your use case, and
it actually builds a spec,
a specification of what needs
to be done in order to customize a model.
You can read that spec. You can edit
that spec.
And then
the AI agent actually helps
take that forward. For example, if it
has to generate synthetic data in order
to train your model, it goes ahead and
generates the synthetic data.
And then with your permission,
it can actually execute the end to end
pipeline as defined in that spec.
So you can go from the spec to
training to evaluation to a production
model just by talking to that agent
in natural language. It's like an AI
expert. That is helping
you with your model customization journey.
Finally, the code-based SDK. This is
super important for full programmatic
control so you can integrate model customization
directly into your
MLOps pipelines.
Now, here is the important thing. Here
is what matters.
These are not three separate
products.
These are three interfaces to the
same underlying service, which is Sagemaker
AI. It's the same
model registry.
It's the same version control, the
same audit trail, so your
security teams
will just see one compliance trail.
So you have 3 different paths,
1 production model,
1 audit trail.
All of these, the 3 paths,
the customization techniques,
it all comes together
in Sagemaker Studio.
Studio is the web based IDE
for your AI workflows.
You get
visual model customization forms
and you get Jupiter notebook
code OSS
visual VS code IDE
for your code-based development, whatever
matches how you work, we provide
all of those development tools in Sage Maker
Studio. And you can seamlessly
switch between them as well, and you're going to see a
demo of StageMaker Studio very, very soon.
But here is what actually matters.
The entire workflow here is
connected
from experimentation
to training to evaluation
to deployment to monitoring. All
of this is connected. It all happens in
one environment.
You can experiment in a notebook.
You can train and evaluate with just
a few click clicks with the form.
When the results meet your bar, you
can click deploy, and the model
goes and gets deployed live
for your inference either on Sagemaker
or on Bedrock.
So I'm excited to share that we are adding
2 more new capabilities into
Sagemaker Studio to make your workflow even
more powerful.
The first is serverless model
evaluation.
It is really super important to be able
to evaluate your models to
understand how they are performing
with this feature. You can evaluate
what actually matters, whether
it is customized model versus
base model,
or when you're doing model customization, different
checkpoints of your customization,
or you may want to experiment with multiple
fine tuning techniques, SFT and
DPO and evaluate them.
We've built several evaluation methods
right into studio.
We provide standard benchmarks
like, for example, um,
multitask language understanding,
the MMLU that you see for
many foundation model benchmarks
that's available in Sagemaker Studio.
Math problem solving benchmarks, they're
available already. There are a bunch of other
standard benchmarks available.
But sometimes you may want to use something like an LLM
as a judge, wherein you enter a custom
prompt to define your evaluation
criteria.
That's available as well.
Or if you want to write your own custom evaluators
to determine
what constitutes good for your model
for your use case,
you can go ahead and bring your custom evaluators as
well, and you're going to see a demo of that very, very soon.
So the idea here is,
you know if your customization
is actually working
before you deploy your model to production.
And most interestingly, all
of this is serverless, so you don't
worry about managing infrastructure,
evaluation infrastructure. You just
focus on actually what you're trying to evaluate
in the model.
The second thing, the second feature I want to
talk about is serverless
ML flow.
Now every model customization
training
on SageMaker
Studio
automatically logs your
metrics, your hyperparametters,
your data sets, your model artifacts.
We've built. Experiment tracking right
into studio. So key metrics
like loss training loss
for your model, they are directly available
in your studio interface.
If you want to dig into more details into
metrics
with one click you can launch MLFlow UI
and you can
start looking into more details into your
model training metrics.
You can view the complete lineage for any
model, you know, things like,
hey, which data trained that model, which
configuration did I use? Who ran that
experiment,
so you know exactly which experiments
are running and you know how to reproduce
them maybe a year later, 6 months
later. Once
again, all of this is serverless. You
don't need to worry about infrastructure. We take care
of it. And here,
the best of all,
there is no additional charge for you to use this
capability.
Now let's talk a little bit about compute
options because you have two options over
here. The first is,
uh, serviceless model customization, and we've
been talking about this, um, a little bit
in the past.
Um, in this case, you
submit a job,
uh, we do the job of provisioning
this GPU cluster,
we take care of distributed training,
you know, model parallel, data parallel,
we take care of all of those details for you,
um. We train the model
and then once the model has been trained,
we tear down the infrastructure.
You only pay for the resources that you actually
use for training. You're not paying for idle
compute resources over here.
This is perfect for rapid
iteration and experimentation,
and this is new. It is launched
as of yesterday.
The second compute option is
for customers who want maximum
control, and this is Sagemaker
Hyperpod.
This is a persistent cluster.
You can share it across
training, inference,
your interactive machine learning
workloads,
and it automatically prioritizes
your workloads
so you can maximize the usage of these
expensive GPU resources.
The killer feature here is resiliency.
Node failures are very common
when you're running a large distributed training
system. Hyperpod automatically
creates checkpoints
and then recovers from checkpoints
and does process level restarts. So
that means that when a fault occurs,
you resume from the last checkpoint,
and this is really cool because it saves
up to 40% of time savings
on a long running job.
Now we try to enhance
this even more. So just yesterday we
launched that hyperpod now supports
checkpoint less training,
so that means that you're going
to be able to recover from your faults
even faster in minutes rather
than hours.
So if you're running your distributed training
job for days or months,
this quickly adds up to huge amounts
of savings.
So I presented these two compute options, which
should you choose for your jobs?
Now, if you're iterating quickly,
training smaller models,
uh, you should simply useser
training. But if you're
running long training jobs
for days or months on frontier
scale models or you want granular
control, you
should be using hyperpod in those cases.
Hyperpod is also super flexible. I've
shown. Here Amazon EKS as the
control plane, but Hyperpod supports
orchestration with both SLUM as
well as EKS. And if you want this kind of granular
control, this is the best way to be
able to train
frontier scale foundation
models. So
finally, let me bring this all together
with the 3 pillars
that comprise
of Sagemaker AI model customization.
The
first is choice.
You're not locked into one model
family or one technique.
You can either use open weight models
or you can use proprietary models. You
can use supervised fine tuning,
direct preference optimization,
reinforcement fine tuning.
You can work through the UI. You can
work through an AI agent. You can
work through an SDK.
You can choose what fits your use
case and your team,
so we give you choice.
The second pillar here is
efficiency.
Serverless training eliminates
infrastructure management.
But if you want control, hyperport
gives you the control when you need it.
The customization technique
that used to take
months before
now takes days,
and you will see Giuseppe demo it
and you can see that it is actually that
simple. So your
teams move faster.
The third is safety.
With enterprises, it is non-negotiable
that safety is like a number one priority.
So you get built-in governance,
built-in lineage, you know what
data was used,
which model was used, which
version of that model was used,
who trained it.
You get IAM-based access
control. Everything operates
securely in your VPC,
and your data never leaves your
control. Choice,
efficiency,
safety. That's how
the customization tax is eliminated,
and you turn foundation models to
your competitive advantage.
Now Giuseppe is going to show you a demo
um that can, that's going to bring all of this
together. The problem that we're going
to be solving in this demo is we want
to customize a LA
33.21 billion
instruct model to sound more
humanlike in conversations.
For that we're going to use a data
set that comprises of
conversational questions and two types
of responses. The first response is
human-like responses, and the second
response is formal responses.
Now we're Giuseppe is going to
show you two demos. In the first demo, he's
going to show you um using
direct preference optimization using a UI-based
workflow.
Remember again, DPO is
where you teach a model judgment and
style by showing it a pair of responses.
In this case we're showing it human-like
responses and formal responses, and
we'll train the model to prefer the
human-like responses.
That's what we're going to be doing with DPO.
And you will see how easy it is to
configure this training without writing
any code. In the
second demo, Giuseppe is going to demonstrate
reinforcement learning with AI feedback, and
this is going to be a code-based workflow.
Again, remember, RLAIF is
a technique wherein a model generates a
response
and gets feedback from an AI
model
as to how that model
is evaluated. It gets a reward,
and then your model that you're training
actually works to maximize
that reward. That's what you're doing with RLAIF.
So it's the same model,
same data set,
two different techniques,
all of it training, running
on Sagemaker AI.
Josepe, take it away.
Thanks, thanks, Sumaida.
Let's move on to the demo part
of this session.
Uh, is the video readable?
That's OK, great.
So we are here on SageMaker AI Studio
and we are going to start the model customization
workflow.
Before we get started, let's take a look at the
dataset that we are going to use today. It's
the human-like dataset
which comes with a prompt,
a chosen response, and a rejected,
rejected response since we want to
use direct preference optimization
here. Great.
In order to use this data
set for model customization in S StageMaker
AI, we can take a look at the supported
formats for the data sets. That's this
new section assets in Sage
Maker AI Studio,
which gives you the opportunity to
collect all your datasets here and version
all your datasets here.
So I can click on upload dataset,
and in the required data input
formats I can find the various input
formats that are required
to customize our model depending on the
technique that we are utilizing. So
for direct preference optimization.
We have a prompt, a chosen,
and a rejected response to be
provided. Indeed, it actually matches
the format of the dataset that we have found
on hugging face.
However, since we also want to
evaluate this model, we are going to do some
data preparation on the dataset to prepare
also the evaluation data set.
And in order to do that,
I've written some simple code in a managed
notebook environment provided by Amazon Sagemaker
Studio to transform the data set and
generate the training and evaluation.
Split.
Great. It's a pretty simple
code. We are just loading the data set
and then you
just observing, observing the structure
of the data set that we have already seen on
the hugging face
website and then you can easily see.
How for a given prompt the chosen
response sounds more humanlike, more
conversational,
and the less preferred, the rejected
response is more like an LLM generated
response which is more artificial, more robotic.
Great. This status, we count the
elements in the data set. It has
around 10,000 elements for training.
We are doing a split of training and evaluation
here with the 10% of the
data set used for evaluation. And
then I'm defining a couple of functions that we're
going to use to transform the data set.
No specific transformation for the
training set,
but just a simple transformation to
obtain a query and response for the
evaluation set.
Then we are executing these
transformations here in this part of the code,
and finally displaying just an example,
a random example from the validation data
set to check that we have achieved the
expected response,
the expected structure.
Finally we can save these data sets
to files or we can decide to upload
the data sets to S3 depending on
how we want to handle the customization
workflow.
OK, great.
Our data is ready.
We can. Jump out of the notebook
environment and we can just
use the functionality in the UI to
upload the data set. I have my training
data set here,
then we can save the data set and
this will just upload the data set to Amazon
S3 object storage and
then store the data set metadata
in the registry. And
if we create the data set here, we should,
um sorry, I forgot giving it a name.
We can put just random name for now.
Then the dataset appears in
the catalog, and we can also take a
look at some samples in this data set.
For example, we can see the first sample just
to check the structure, that's what's
your favorite type of cuisine and then
the chosen response, I'm a big fan of
Italian cuisine.
I promise that I didn't put any bias
in this data set.
Great. Let's
move on to the model customization
itself. We're going to customize
a LAMA 3.21 billion
model so
we can search in this new model
hub.
We can search for our model, which is the
3.21 billion instruct.
This is just a model detailed page with all the
information about the model, and then we can move
to the customized section, this
new customized with UI or customize
with code section.
Let's go with the customization through the user
interface,
and what we need to do here is
giving it a name to our model,
give the custom model a name,
then we can choose the technique that we want to use
direct preference optimization
for the data set. We could have also uploaded the
data set here, but since I already have the
dataset in the registry, then
I can select my data set.
And then we find a number
of defaults already configured
in the user interface like the output
location where we want our artifacts to be stored.
As well as the hyperparameter configuration,
all of that comes
out of the box preconfigured recipes
for you to get started. You don't have to
necessarily modify these parameters, but if you want,
you can change the parameters according
to the results of your experiments. And then
you also have an advanced configuration
section where other hyperparameterss
can be tuned, as well as
the configuration of the MLFlow
application that we want to use for experiment tracking.
Um, you know,
you, you,
you can, you know, set that in this, in this
section.
Great, um, yeah,
what we then need to do is just submit
our job
and accept, and
this will trigger a training job,
which is the actual customization job.
This will take some time. We are training for 3
epochs. It's around 1
hour training based on my experiments,
so. What I'm going to do
is show you an example
that I have already pre-run
for DPO.
We can take a look at the custom model
screen, which is where you will land after the customization
job gets executed, and
here you can see
first of all you can see the logs from the model
training. In this
screen we can also look at the performance
that we have achieved some performance metrics
for our job.
One interesting
metric is the margin of the rewards,
which represents essentially the
difference between the rewards
given from our model to the chosen versus
the rejected response. So it means that in some
way it can give us an indication
on how the model is learning.
And if we want to browse
the full metrics, we can open
MLflow directly from the user interface,
and this will open the serverless MLflow
interface
to dive deep into the various model metrics
and how our
training has been behaving great.
We have run
the fine tuning. The model is ready.
The next thing that we might want to do
is test this model very quickly, run
some inferences, and see if we have
really fine tuned and adapted our model
with respect to the task that we wanted
to achieve. In order to do that, we can
use the deploy functionality which is
still available from the user interface
and You can decide to deploy to Sage
maker or you can deploy to serverless
inference in Bedrock. In the case of Sage
maker, you can choose whether using an existing
endpoint that is already running, and
this means that
Sage maker gives you the ability to
bring back models on an existing endpoint
infrastructure so that you can optimize
on the cost,
or you can create a brand new
endpoint. Let's create a new endpoint,
for example, and just in a few clicks
we give a name to the endpoint.
The compute
I type is already pre-selected
based on the model
that we have fine tuned, and we can just
hit deploy.
Deployment. I'm not going to run deployment for
now, but we can go back to the model
screen where I have already run a deployment
and look at the details of the deployment.
We can see here that we have our
Model deployed
to the endpoint and since
for the model training we use
the lower techniques to optimize
the fine tuning
process we have we have deployed
on the endpoint the
service automatically deploys on the endpoint
both the base model as
well as the adapters as separate
components and the reason is that in this
way you have the. Ability to load
multiple adapters on the same endpoint
that would be merged at one time
with the base model to execute the inference. This
is an additional optimization functionality
that Sagemaker provides.
Great. Let's see indeed if our model
gave us some good results, and
we can use this playground to do that.
Here on the right hand side you can choose which
model you want to invoke, whether the base model or
the fine tuned one.
Let's try to invoke
the base model.
With a simple question.
How are you today?
And the base model is replying,
I'm
just a language model. I don't have
emotions or feelings and so on. So the
response that we would expect
from the genetic model.
Now let's see if I just
try to invoke the adapter and clear the
conversation. Today
We can see that indeed we are having a
way more informal response
from our model, including emoticons, exclamation
marks, and so on.
Great, but that's not enough. We have deployed
the model. We want to actually assess its
performance using an evaluation data set
and how can I do that?
So we have a built-in capability
from the user interface to evaluate
our model, to set up an evaluation.
And the way you can do that, so you can use multiple
techniques as Sumaida mentioned,
you can use
standard well known benchmarks for doing
that. You can implement a customs
coder which is essentially using
code, your own function to evaluate
the model,
or you can use the LLM as a judge
technique where we are asking.
And another bigger model
to judge the response that
is coming from our model
with respect also to the ground truth that
we are providing to the model from
the evaluation set that we
that we select as an input.
Great. That's indeed what I have used
as a technique to evaluate this model
and
There are multiple models that we can choose for
the evaluation. I've chosen Cloud
3.5 for this evaluation,
and on the metrics side you have some built-in
metrics, but as you can imagine
for evaluating how a model,
the tone and style of a model,
we might want to use a custom metric
and instruct our judge model
on how to interpret whether
the responses from the fine-tuned model
are actually humanlike
responses. And that's what indeed
I have done, and you can indeed use
the custom metric screen to do that.
Custom metric screen is
Supports both importing a metric
that you have saved in a JSON file
for your consumption at any
time, or you can use the custom
screen where you can input the instructions
that you want to provide to the judge model. You
can also select a scale type
for rating the response
that has been provided
by your model,
and this rate,
scale, the scale type could be numerical
or categorical.
Let's take a look at the metric that
I want to use for this evaluation.
That I have defined is called humanlike
metric, and as you can see we have a few instructions.
I hope this is readable,
but we have a few instructions
which instruct indeed the
large model on how to evaluate
the outputs from the fine-tuned model
with respect also to the ground truth that we
are providing from the evaluation data set.
Indeed you can see here that we have some placeholders
for the prompt, the ground truth,
and the prediction.
Great, let's see.
The results that they have achieved,
well, the remaining steps here are just about
specifying the data set that we want to use
and submitting the evaluation job. Let's
see the results that I have
achieved on this model. I've run a
few evaluations, but
we can take a look at the evaluation results from
this screen
using LLM as a judge.
And as you can see, we have here all the
records that have been evaluated
also with respect to the base model.
So I have decided to compare side by side
the base model results
and the fine tuned model results, and
we can see here that for example for
this prompt the base
model score was somewhat
kind of humanlike for the humanlike metric
for the custom model it's completely
and so forth for the various prompts,
but the results that you get from the evolut.
are still accessible at any time.
So while you see these results from the user
interface, they are still accessible at any
time from S3, which
you see the links here for the base
model evaluation results and the custom
model evaluation results. Indeed, what I have done
to to have an overall summary
of the evaluation results, I have.
Downloaded these results,
those who are stored in the S3 bucket
to my notebook, and then I've mapped
the various categories of the scores,
not at all, somewhat and completely
to numbers so that I can compare
the Responses on the overall
results and then what I get with the
simple function is that our fine-tuned
model has improved in 49%
of the cases with respect to the base model
as equal performance for 41%
of the cases and in about 10%
of the cases as a degraded
degraded performance according to the
judge model that we have used for this
evaluation. Great.
Finally, before we move to the next
example, I wanted to show you that
all the actions that we execute
in in the user interface are
tracked, and we get the full lineage graph
of the operations that we have
executed. We can check this from the
UI. And as you can see
for the model that we are customizing,
we get all the links to the
training job that was used for customization
as well as the deployments that we have executed
and the various evaluation runs and
so forth.
Great. Finally, last thing
on this example, you can always
continue the customization
starting from the fine tuned
model that we have obtained by
either changing hyperparametters on the customization
using the same technique or changing
completely the technique.
Great. This concludes
the DPO demo. Let
me move now to the
Code-based workflow.
So whatever we have done in the user interface
can be achieved using this SageMaker
Python SDK as a code-based
workflow.
So similar to the previous example,
I have
prepared the data set. I will skip these
steps
because they are almost the same steps. The
only thing to note here is that for
reinforcement learning with AI feedback.
The structure of the input format
is slightly different because we want
to provide the model that
is going to give us the feedback on
the generated responses from the fine-tuned
model. We need to give this model, we
can give this model,
the ground truth information.
That's the expected structure that you
can find also from the same
user interface where the dataset
formats are defined.
For evaluation, we are using the same the
same
format.
Great, I will not spend too much
time on these data preparation stages, but
what I want to show you then
is that we are uploading the
two datasets to S3 in this case, so
we are not using the user interface for
the upload. We just upload via code to S3.
Then what we are doing is we are importing
from this
module SageMaker AI registry the
dataset class,
and this helps us creating
the datasets, so the same operation that we have
seen. The user interface can be done from
the user interface we create from the
programmatic interface,
so we create the two datasets that get
added to the registry.
Then the next important thing
is defining the reward prompt.
So what the model,
the feedback model, needs to
look at to understand how to
score the responses from
the model that we are fine tuning at each iteration
of the reinforcement learning. and
this is the prompt that I have used. You can
see that it's a pretty
sophisticated prompt to check for
if some response is humanlike or not,
but what is important is that we need
to return from this prompt
adjacent that contains the score
in a range that I have defined from
0 to 1,
the score that has been given by the
feedback model
to the prompt to the.
Responses generated by the
model that we are fine tuning through reinforcement,
reinforcement learning.
Great. Once we define the reward prompt,
just to show you where this ends, it
ends up being available also in the evaluator's
screen inmer AI Studio, so you
can review the prompt at any time and
take a look at what the structure
of the prompt is and the text also
from the user interface.
Great. Next
thing that we have to do is define the
name of the model,
the same thing that we have seen in the UI. We will
do, we will create
the name for the custom model that we are
fine tuning
and The
key step here is using the
trainer class of the decision maker
Python SDK which configures the
reinforcement learning with the AI feedback
process, and this class takes as input
the base model
that is indeed set to LAA
3.21 billion instruct.
It needs the information about the reward
model and in this case as a reward
model for the reinforcement learning, we
are using 120
billion. And then a
few other parameters for the S3
location where we want the outputs to be stored, the
input data set that
we are providing for the fine tuning and
so forth. Great.
After we create the class, we have
this method which is called we
have property to access the hyperparametters
and look at the default configuration of the hyper
parameters, but we can also set
the various hyperparameter values as needed.
For example, in this case,
I wanted to just train for one epoch, and
I have modified the configuration of
the hyperparametters.
Finally, the last step is
running the train, so calling
the train method of the
trainer to execute the training to
trigger the training job.
Great. What
the result of this operation
is available already in my UI,
and I can show you the model that I
have trained.
And it's indeed
Here For
this model we are getting quite
interesting results as well as you can
see we have
the rewards which are increasing,
which we expect, and also the policy
entropy is decreasing, which means
that the models during the reinforcement learning
is going towards more exploitation
rather than exploration. So it means that it's
kind of converging in the right direction.
Great. Same thing, we can monitor the metrics
from ML flow.
But again,
now let's take a look at if
we had good results with fine tuning
this model. I have also deployed
this model to a age make a real-time
end point. We can go
and open the playground and see
what we get from this model, and
we can ask the same question, Hey,
how are you today?
And well, that's the expected answer
also in this case from the base model. Now
let's take a look at the adapter model
that we have fine tuned. Let's clear the
conversation. Hey,
how are you
today? We
see that again we have a more informal,
more humanlike response from
the model, although as you can see in this
case, we don't see a lot of
emoticons or exclamation
marks, and the main reason here
is that
We are getting the feedback from
another large language model and we didn't
instruct this model
to give more weight to this kind of
style, so we didn't put this,
we didn't inform the model towards
to achieve this objective.
Great. Similar to the previous
example, we can see how the evaluation
is triggered.
The same evaluation with as judge
can be triggered using SageMaker
Python as the case,
same thing that we have seen in the UI, and
we are doing exactly the
same type of evaluation that I have
run for the
use case.
And in order to do that,
the custom metrics are defined
as adjacent.
In the
in this variable custom metric list for
LLM as a judge, and then
I'm running,
I'm using this class LLM as a judge evaluator
to execute the
LLM as a judge task
and the model that we are using
as an evaluator in this case is anthropic cloud
3.5, so the same, the same model
that we used in the previous case.
For sure it's important to make sure that we are using
a different model from the reward model that
we use
during the during the AI feedback.
Great. That said,
we can then run the evaluator evaluate
method and this
produces the evaluation that you
see. In this
screen. Which has
similar results to
the previous evaluation. We have a prompt
the model response, the base score, custom
score
that have been provided by the judge
model, and now we can again
compare
the results, the overall results
using just a couple of
lines of code
and
We can see that in 74%
of the cases here
our model has improved
and has equal performance
in 24% of the cases degraded
way less
than the other models.
Well, that's kind of expected because
we have used a large language,
large language model as a reward model
during the reinforcement learning, and then we have used
another large language model to evaluate
the performance,
but we didn't consider specific aspects
as for example, including emoticons
and so on. So the
expectation would be that the evaluation
run through entropic cloud in this case would
have been, would have been higher.
Great. That said,
This concludes the
the demo
for today.
Thanks, and we can now move
back to the presentation.
So the key that I would like you to note here
is Giuseppe very, very
seamlessly moved between the UI
and the SDK.
What you were actually able to do in the SDK, you can come
into the UI. This is really what I meant by
saying that
these are not different products, right?
That is the same service.
Depending upon who you are as a user, you
can choose which interface you want
or maybe you know, mix and match different interfaces.
And I don't know how many of you, how
many of you have actually tried running reinforcement
learning by yourself.
These are all extremely complex
model customization techniques, and
you're able to actually with a few clicks
or a few lines of code you're
able to actually run that and actually add
real business value,
and these are all production recipes
like we have a large team of
scientists who are actually building these
recipes so that customers such as you
can actually use these and run these in production.
So our goal here is to make all of
the customization techniques as accessible
to you as possible,
and I hope you saw a glimpse of
what this experience looked like,
looks like. Please feel free to explore more of
this on Sagemaker Studio,
uh, and we have uh
lots more to uh to
tell you folks. So feel free to reach out to us and
we're happy to talk to you about it.
Thank you so much.